grievers nearly everything he said I
think he's hit the nail on the head it
it's really exciting step forward
especially for patients like in this
clinical trial they have advanced skin
cancer that skin cancer that's already
spread they don't really have an awful
lot of treatment options available and
just say a decade ago their outlook was
really quite big league but thanks to
targeted therapies and these new
immunotherapies they could be looking at
years years of cancer free survival and
being a healthy happy functioning adult
but it's what degree should people be
hopeful I mean it people think great
that sounds amazing but as we saying
there it won't work for patients is
there a danger here that may get
people's hopes up perhaps without good
calls yes it's not a cure it's not a
miracle cure we do need to stress that
and that's one challenge we do need to
work out who is actually going to
respond to these drugs and other the
people that don't why don't they and are
there better combinations that we could
offer them better ways we could use
these drug to actually stimulate a
response in them too but it's not going
to be a miracle cure and it's also not
going to replace the cornerstones of
cancer treatment like surgery and
radiotherapy to get back to skin cancer
surgery especially during the early
stages its curative there's absolutely
no need to come in with immunotherapies
at this point but where it's really
going to come to the forefront is for
patients who aren't going to respond to
radio therapy or surgery anymore and
then we can start to look at using these
immunotherapies whereby the other
options are limited but what about the
cost aspect of this because you look at
the kind of course I've been talked
about there in our report can you really
see the NHS being able to afford to
adopt this on a significant scale I
think we need to point out the one in
the drugs that was involved in the clear
control is already an option for
patients in the UK it's available from
the NHS for patients with advanced skin
cancer some of these drugs are actually
available in the clinic now the NHS will
pay for them because they're so
effective we're talking about more than
one drug they want me in this form of
therapy in this particular clinical
trial yes but there are other drugs that
are coming through that have the same
kind of mechanism of action and it could
be that these new drugs will be cheaper
and as a charge of has some research UK
what to say to people listening as
people might say rocky that's it jobs
done we found the real breakthrough does
that sound like perhaps we don't need as
much extra funds being poured into
Castle yeah absolutely not we've not
there yet don't
this was just a trial in malignant
melanoma there are still lots of other
cancers which urgently need better
treatments like pancreatic cancer and
lung cancer and immunotherapy is still
at its beginnings we've still got some
big challenges ahead some big questions
that need answering the doctor mentioned
talking about side effects we need to
look at how to manage those better
extending my sugar they can be quite
severe yes and doctors have been using
things like chemotherapy and
radiotherapy for years so they're
actually very good at dealing with the
side effects like there are very good
anti sickness drugs now radiotherapy has
become very precise exactly to less than
the side effects so one of the next book
challenges is learning how to control
the side effects that come with
immunotherapies so of course we always
need more money for research there's
lots more we can and need to be doing to
make sure that cancer is a disease that
people don't fear anymore son son could
be on the right path as well dr. Smith
actually thank you